les vœux se poursuivent pour les
responsables politique en ce mois de
janvier vendredi soir c'était au tour de
Guima Landin le maire socialiste de
trappe que faut-il en retenir le point
avec Catherine zulato bonsoir Catherine
bonsoirfri bonsoir à tous Alors les vœux
se suivent j'ai envie de dire et se
ressembleent à trrappe d'une certaine
manière puisqu'une fois encore Guy
bandin a fait du chantier de la
nationalist sa priorité pour 2013 alors
pas d'annonce particulière sur le
calendrier mais évidemment une volonté
forte de voir aboutir l'enfouissement
d'une partie de cet axe fréquenté je le
rappelle par 80000 véhicules tous les
jours il a parlé de signneau positifs en
provenance des différents ministères en
charge du dossier et qui doivent se
prononcer sur l'aspect technique reste
tout de même une difficulté de taille le
montant des travaux estimés à environ 80
millions d'euros et les caisses de
l'État plutôt vides en ce moment mais
Guy Malandin s'est dit confiant après le
contact pris avec le nouveau ministre du
Transport Frédéric
cuvilleriv t les réalisations de 2012
qui ont été valorisé le maire a fait le
point et oui à travers une longue vidéo
que nous avons découvert l'envers tout
d'abord de la nouvelle cuisine centrale
qui vient d'ouvrir ses portes 2200 repas
préparés tous les jours avec une
priorité aux produits locaux également à
l'honneur le travail mené sur le plan
culturel par la salle de spectacle la
Merise et puis l'association envie alors
l'association envie on y répare on y
traite des déchets électroménagers mais
surtout on y fait de l'accompagnement de
personnes en réinsertion professionn ce
sont des des CDD d'insertion qui
occupent les postes notamment
d'opérateurs de vendeurs de chauffeurs
et le public lui peut acheter des objets
comme neufs à des prix défiant toute
concurrence il a même une garantie et
puis un long volet aussi éducatif hein
pour le maire de trappe qui a rappelé la
mise en place de la maison des parents
du conseil des droits et devoirs de la
famille les opérations coup pouce
notamment et puis il a aussi fait perdd
d'un courrier ça ça va intéresser les
parents d'élèves du président du conseil
régional Jean-Paul Huchon en date du 18
décembre dernier qui a fait état de la
rénovation globale du lycée de la plaine
de naufle dans le cadre du plan
pluriannel de la région et on sait que
les professeurs sont souvent mobilisés
dans cet établissement là ils seront
certainement contents de la prendre
voilà pour les différents dossiers qui
ont été abordés pour faire le point sur
2012 sur un plan plus politique à
présent est-ce qu'il y a eu des choses à
remarquer alors des V du ma de trou il y
a eu des choses mais avant juste une
petite parenthèse pour signaler qu'aux
associations sportives qui jugent les
donations trop faible et ben Guy
Malandin a répondu qu'une remise à plat
totale était prévue plusieurs clubs se
pl ne d'un manque de soutien financier
pour répondre à leurs objectifs sportifs
et la priorité sera donnée à l'avenir au
nombre de licenciés des club pardon et
puis sur un plan pur politique vous en
parliez et bien on on retiendra
notamment laavenue ce n'est pas une
surprise du ministre de l'économie
sociale et solidaire Benoît amont qui
était donc présent pour cette cérémonie
de vœux il y a quelques jours sur notre
antenne le ministre se disait prêt a
envisagé sa présence pour les futurs
municipales de mars 2014 sur la liste du
maire sortant et bien guimalandin lui
aussi est prêt à en parler voilà deux
personnes qui s'entendent bien il nous
l'a confié en aparté tout dépendra
évidemment de la loi sur le nom cumule
des mandats et rappelons d'ailleurs que
guimalandin n'est pas forcément
favorable à cette réforme car pour lui
un exécutif local est indispensable pour
ne pas se couper des réalités du terrain
merci Catherine gimalandin qui marque
une fois de plus donc sa différence avec
la ligne de son parti prochaine
cérémonie de vœux dont nous parlerons
dans ce 78 ce sera les vœux du président
de l'agglomération de C eneline Robert
Cadalbert les vœux du président
socialiste programmé demain mardi merci
Catherine on reste dans la politique
avec le point sur les premières
élections conseil municipal des jeunes à
la verrière et puis juste après culture
l'auteur Xavier Deutch qui rencontre
actuellement à Saint-Quentin en iveline
des élèves de 3e et de seconde pour
parler de son avant-dernier ouvrage 11
50 % de participation pour une première
élection réussie 10 jeunes électeurs ont
exprimé leur voix la semaine dernière
pour élire leur représentant au Conseil
municip des jeunes de la verrière 21
conseillers de 11 à 15 ans ont été élus
ainsi que 6 suppléentss pour le premier
CMJ de la ville ces derniers seront
présentés lors des vœux du maire Alain
Haage vendredi 18 janvier les jeunes
sont une telle richesse une
telle t foisonnement d'idée que on peut
pas passer à côté de ça
doncens c'était important de le
permettre de
s'exprimeres tout
jeunesésent participer à une première
réunion de leurs habits d'él dès la fin
du mois mais là ça va être à l'envers là